you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact the world is facing a sand
shortage I'll bet those are some words
you've probably never thought you'd hear
it's true
more than iron coal or timber sand has
now become the world's most widely
consumed natural resource after fresh
water most houses skyscrapers and
bridges are made with concrete which is
of course two-thirds sand the annual
world consumption of sand is estimated
to be 15 billion tons and China's demand
for sand has increased exponentially by
437 percent over the last 20 years sand
once widely considered to be limitless
is now emerging as a threatened resource
you might be thinking the world is
covered by deserts and filled with sand
but the round grains of sand found in
the desert do not bind well so they
can't be used for most concentrated
purposes or most construction purposes
for example Dubai which is surrounded by
desert sand has used up all of its
quality marine sand now Dubai must
import sand from Australia to maintain
its ongoing building frenzy high-quality
sand or more precisely silicon is needed
to produce computer chips and micro
processors and many other products most
glass makers use only fine white silica
sand some geologists estimate that the
world only has about a twenty year
supply remaining of the fine silica sand
did you know the Bible says that there
are several promises and prophecies
related to sand stay with us friends
we're going to learn more on this
edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
my name is Sean Ross good evening
Franzen pastor Dyke it's good to be
doing Bible answers live again this
evening I know we've had a couple weeks
where you were gone or I would I was
gone but it's good to be back together
and we also want to greet our Facebook
friends who are joining us also alive
and if you have a Bible question the
phone line here to the studio is one
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven and that'll bring you here
with your Bible question well faster
right before we go to the phone lines
let's start with the word of Prayer dear
father once again we are grateful for
the opportunity to spend some time
opening up your word and studying
together we do ask for the Holy Spirit
to come and guide our hearts our minds
be with those who are listening in Jesus
name Amen amen
well pastor that you open the program
talking about sand and of course we take
sand for granted we hear a lot about the
deserts that are growing and all of the
sand in the deserts but you brought up a
good point that there's it's and isn't
really that useful especially when it
comes to construction you need a
different kind of sand which is actually
running out amazing
yeah the sand that comes down from the
mountains you find deposited either on
the seashore by rivers that has like
rough edges and it bonds well with
concrete desert sand because it's been
blown by the wind and the waters for a
long time it's all around and it just it
doesn't work
and you never would think that we could
run out of good sand for construction
and for windows and fur and these things
but they've actually gotten India they
got a sand mafia because the market is
so fierce for the sand and you know it
makes me think about you think of
Santa's being something limitless and
many times in the prophecies God said to
Abraham that someday your descendants
will be like the sand on the seashore we
often use that expression at isaiah 40:8
19 it says your descendants also would
have been like the sand and your
offspring of your body like the grains
of sand but there's another prophecy in
the Bible where it talks about what some
believe is concrete you know when you
look at the image of Daniel chapter 2
the kingdoms of the world are outlined
where talks about this dream that
Nebuchadnezzar had where there's a head
of gold the arms are silver the belly is
bronze the legs are iron and the feet
are a mixture of iron and it says miry
clay and you'll find that mentioned in
Daniel chapter 2 verse 43 well I heard a
couple of theologians that have
postulated the number one building
material in the world today is concrete
that is reinforced with iron and if you
are an ancient Bible prophet and you are
trying to say what is it what are they
making the buildings out of today
they're not using stone like the Tower
of Babel they use miry clay is what it
would look like there's a gray mushy
substance mixed in with iron and it's
just kind of amazing that it is the
number one building material in the
world today and some those kingdoms in
Daniels dream take us down from the time
of Babylon medo-persia Greece Rome and
then the divisions of the Roman Empire
of the ten toes so we're we're living in
the world today and then you've got the
the two beasts that are mentioned it's
like there's two legs on that and do
feet and you get the the two beasts that
are found in Revelation 13 many believe
that one of those beasts is dealing with
Cassata Catholicism based on
in Rome and Protestantism based in the
United States and we get a lot of
questions about prophecy and the United
States don't we we do and we have
something if you've had questions about
that then we have a special free offer
that we're gonna make available tonight
it's one of our amazing facts study
guides and it's called the u.s. in Bible
prophecy and again it deals with this
passage of Scripture that you find in
Revelation chapter 13 just a very
important study and I think you'll find
this very helpful it's free all you're
left to do is give us a call and ask for
it again the study guide is called the
us in Bible prophecy and the phone line
is eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven that is our resource
phone line and just ask for the study
guide called the u.s. in Bible prophecy
again that number is 885 six seven four
seven or pass tonight I think we're
ready to go to the phone line so we've
got Joseph listening in the u.s. Joseph
wharff of the program hi thank you so
much thank you and your question um is
there any significance in mm and
inversely of Jesus baptism crucifixion
and the stoning of Stephen well right
now Jesus was baptized as near as we can
tell about 27 ad we know that he
ministered three and a half years and he
died in 31 ad Stephen was stoned about
three and a half years after that in 34
AD
there's no we're not commanded to
celebrate the anniversary you mean is
this some kind of benchmark that would
have some prophetic fulfillment that we
reach 2,000 years from that event yeah
recently sorry yeah we had 500
anniversary of Luther's protest right so
similarly is there any prophetic
significance in the 2000 if we say 6,000
years ago Adam and Eve were created you
know there's no command that we would
know anything about the time of Christ's
coming so I don't know of any prophecy
that points
2,000 years beyond Jesus baptism - any
event happening although it is
interesting you did bring up a something
that he's been around for quite a while
and they referred to that as the great
week of time and the significance of
seven in the Bible you find God working
for six days in creation and then he
rested on the seventh day and some see
that is at least an outline of off world
history where the earth is inhabited for
6,000 years then Jesus comes in this the
1000 year millennial rest in the new
earth is recreated after that so that is
interesting I think there's something
there but we don't know for sure when we
reach that 6,000 year mark writes all
kinds of speculations and ideas out
there but we've already actually passed
the time of 2,000 years from Christ's
birth right we have not passed the time
of 2,000 years from his baptism or his
death or a resurrection so we've got to
be careful about saying what that means
but it does I do think that we know the
time is near because we're in like the
sixth millennium which is like sundown
before you have the thousand-year kind
of a Sabbath millennium and we do
appreciate your question Joseph do you
have we have our special offer maybe on
the second coming that we could make
available we do we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks and
it's called anything but secret it's a
book dealing with the second coming to
receive that give us a call on the
resource line that's 883 five six seven
four seven and again you can ask for the
book called anything but secret annex
koley's Zain listening from Upland
California Zane welcome to the program
it's great to be here thank you thanks
for calling in your question um so I
have a friend who is struggling a lot to
understanding the Bible in God and I'm
trying to help him understand but I
don't have the best answer for this
question that he is struggling with and
that what's the proof for the existence
of God well I wish we had about 60
minutes right now because I just
preached a sermon and the title of the
sermon is evidence for God or can you
prove that there
Oh God now you'll find that online
probably in YouTube or you can for free
but I can give you a couple of high
points very quickly one would be that
science is more and more coming to the
conclusion that because of the
complexity of life and when they look
through these super electron microscopes
and they look at the formation of matter
that there's so much interworking design
and organization that you do not get
this kind of intelligent systems that
are functioning without an outside
intelligence organizing it so there must
be an original outside intelligence to
produce all of the intelligent life and
the interworking systems and the
symbiotic relationships and and so that
to me I think is as strong as the other
evidence is there's so many things that
happen that seem to be providential that
you would just think there has to be a
god I'll give you a small story I
thought of this week I traveled went out
of state left my phone charger I thought
on though what am I going to do now I
need my phone for everything I forgot my
charger I prayed about it got to my
hotel room imagine my surprise when in
the hotel wall somebody had left a
charger that fit my phone of course I
used it and gave it to the hotel desk
charge my phone but I mean what are the
odds of that you know so many things
like that I could cite that you just
know there has to be a god kiss of
Providence and so take a look at that
sermon and I don't know if there's
anything specifically we can offer on
well we got wonders of creation we also
have a book on the Bible and of course
if people can see that the Bible is
trustworthy then what the Bible says is
trustworthy with reference to God that's
right there's evidence the Bible can be
trusted the book is called the ultimate
resource and it's about the Bible and
it's just a great read and we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls an
- the number is 883 five six seven four
seven and you can ask for the book
called the ultimate resource it's about
the Bible and of course the Bible will
give you all the evidences you need for
the existence of God what's that number
again the number one more time is eight
hundred eight three five six seven
fourths
and we'll be happy to send it to anyone
who calls and asks our next caller that
we have is Chris listening in Chicago
Chris welcome to the program hi pastor
Doug Pastor John how you doing I'm not
too bad yourself
great we're glad you called in your
question change this is trying to hurt I
call it because I wanted to know in
leviticus where moses wrote down the
laws and like what their consequences
were if they still apply today well
there i'm sorry go ahead
because uh like for certain things they
said you were they were an abomination
to the lord and and you were just like
dads to death so they still know it
still applies well let me ask you
different questions
Chris before I answer your question that
you sound like from the emotion in your
voice that you've broken one of these
and you're in trouble
I broken two of them but I didn't
realize what they were I started reading
Bible let me just explain that the big
question is does God forgive and the
Bible tells us all different kinds of
sin that God forgives now without going
into the specifics of what you may be
struggling with I strongly recommend
that you just you you pray when we hang
up and ask the Lord to forgive your sins
whatever it is and believe that the
sacrifice of Jesus that he'll do that
because he long mister forgive you and
give you a new life back to your
original question as far as the law of
Moses is concerned when you read in
Deuteronomy when God gives Moses the Ten
Commandments now it's chapter four of
Deuteronomy Deuteronomy after numbers in
Leviticus chapter four if you go to
verse 13 it says he declared to you the
words oh well let me see I'm is this the
101 yeah verse 14 and the LORD commanded
me at that time
to teach you statutes and judgments that
you might observe them before that he
says he declared his covenant he
commanded you to perform the Ten
Commandments
and he wrote them on two tables of stone
and the LORD commanded me at that time
to teach me statutes and judgments so
Moses explains not only did God give the
Ten Commandments that's the moral law
for all eternity there are other
statutes and judgments and some of these
were ceremonial laws and that were
nailed to the cross
some are civil laws and there are health
laws or several categories of laws that
God gave Moses on the mountain and you
know the ceremonial laws are no longer
required the moral laws it's very clear
but Chris hey would you mind if I just
prayed with you before we went to the
next call and help you to find the peace
that Jesus offers would that be all
right fine all right
Father in Heaven I just pray that you'll
be with Chris and just bless him with
your spirit I ask Florida that you help
him to find peace and regardless of the
struggles that he's encountered to
believe that Jesus blood is powerful
enough to wash away all sin and we ask
this in Jesus name Amen amen
now we have a book that we can offer
Chris it's called three steps to heaven
Chris we'd like to send you a copy of
that book and please read it it'll give
you some encouragement the number to
call is 800 eight three five six seven
four seven and again just asked for the
book called three steps to heaven
that number is 888-259-3826
yes and yeah and he was witnessing to
the pagans and he didn't use much
scripture so can you explain that yeah
yeah when you're you know of course you
quote scripture to people that recognize
the validity of Scripture when Paul was
preaching to the the Greek pagans there
in Athens they had very little knowledge
of or respect for scriptures so for him
to say but the Bible says this and the
Bible says that well if they don't know
about the Bible and they don't know
about the authority of the Bible he had
to start somewhere else so Paul started
by pointing to one of the idols they
worshiped he said look you got an idol
that you've made to an unknown God let
me tell you about that God that you
worship in ignorance and so he used that
as a bridge to start telling them about
Jesus and eventually you bring people
into study of the Bible where they
depend on the Bible at amazing facts
when people are looking to come to Jesus
we start out by giving them our first
Bible study that talks about the
validity and the power of Scripture so
it builds their confidence in Scripture
so then you can quote the Bible later on
I see okay I understand
al an answer that we'd be happy to send
you our first study in the Bible it's
called anything left you can trust I
think pastor Ross just offered that to
someone else a moment it's the number to
call is 800 III five six seven four
seven as for the study guide called is
there anything left you can trust
talking about the Bible and how we can
trust the Bible indeed our next caller
the behalf is looks like Cindy's calling
from Minnesota Cindy welcome to the
program thank you thank you for calling
my question is I know you don't have to
be circumcised to become a Christian but
after you're a Christian do you need to
be circumcised No
you know Paul says pretty clearly in
Galatians in a number of other places
that is a circumcision as nothing
uncircumcision is nothing you can read
in Acts chapter 15 and the New Testament
church had a pretty lengthy debate
wondering whether or not the
converts to Christianity had to be
circumcised than they came to the
conclusion no they don't need to be
circumcised even after their they accept
Jesus and they're saved it was not a
requirement people before the time of
Abraham like Noah and Enoch and Adam
were saved based on the faith in the
blood of the Lamb they were not
circumcised circumcision was a covenant
that was given to the Jewish nation to
point them to Jesus that the holy seed
of the Christ was going to come through
Abraham to Christ it also was a symbol
for cutting away of the flesh meaning
you would not be carnally minded but
spiritually minded and so you know what
the coming to Christ the ceremonial law
passed away and circumcision was part of
that Paul makes it pretty clear when he
says that circumcision is nothing
uncircumcision is nothing
what matters is keeping the commandments
okay that's great and by the way that is
if that's 1st Corinthians 7 19
circumcision is nothing uncircumcision
is nothing but keeping the commandments
is what matters
okay well that's pretty clear thank you
very much Thank You Cindy appreciate
your call yeah you're welcome
bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye next for the
behalf is calling from Brooklyn New York
Monty welcome to the program Carla
pastor thank you for taking my call I
tried that sweet but you had trouble
with your phones I believe we did thanks
for calling back
yeah what I wanted to know I know God
said that when he created everything
that it was good
each time he created something and that
when the animals went to Noah who didn't
find them they came to him and God had
to speak to them I guess to get them to
go on the ark because lions and tigers
would I gather wouldn't walk up an arc
you know onto a ship by themselves so
this is my question
is there any scripture where an animal
was healed or animals were healed in the
Bible well let me think about that there
are there's a scripture where God spoke
through an animal that's the donkey of
Balaam you've got the scripture where
two cows were guided by God these cows
were carrying the Ark of the Covenant
and they were guided by God from the
land of the Philistines back to the Land
of Israel
you've got the Ravens that came and they
fed to Elisha and you know Jesus had
several illustrations about the animals
but I don't know of an animal I don't
know of a prophecy where an animal was
sick and then was healed so I think I'd
have to say there's no record of that in
the Bible but you know the Bible does
say a righteous man regards the life of
his Beast and even in the Sabbath
commandment it says that you should make
sure your beast gets proper rest
not only were people the rest they were
to let their beasts of burden rest so
that's as close as I think we can come
God certainly cares about animals he
made them well what I thought was said
you know should time you pray for people
God heals so he wants to heal some
people are healed some aren't so I've
been praying for a certain animal and
you know I know God hears my prayer and
that possibly he would heal this animal
well you know what it is absolutely true
that God has the ability to do that and
so you know then we do have a book that
I think we carry it's called will my
pets be in heaven you might enjoy that
one you know God can heal animals I'm
sure
pastor Ross would agree with me on that
he answers prayer and we've all had pets
have gotten sick healing is part of the
process of all life you know God can
heal all kinds of animals I had a
goldfish I'm ashamed to say that I
thought for sure had died we had this
goldfish for years I thought it had died
and so I I dumped him in the toilet I
didn't know what else to do and yeah he
came back to life and I had reach into
the toilet and get him back out again I
think there was just not enough oxygen
in his fish tank so I'm gonna get
letters about that anyway he was
resurrected with the last place in the
world you think he'd be resurrected I
Steve Wahlberg is the author it's called
will my pet be in heaven I know amazing
fact carries it and you could probably
buy it just online with amazon it's not
expensive will my pet be in heaven
you'll enjoy that mati thank you so much
for your question tonight big swallow
that we have is calling from Hawaii we
have Johnny Johnny welcome to the
program Johnny on the line from Hawaii
you still there Johnny may have his mute
on hi sorry about that I did have it on
hey how'd you survive the hurricane oh
we made it we expect the worst but it
never came all right well that's we're
thankful for that they never really it
wasn't it broke off it kind of broke off
before weeks Oh wahoo but the Big Island
got real bad they got hit pretty hard
and what's your question sighing Johnny
yes um I want to know what does the
Bible say about spiritual abuse when you
know leadership that abused their
authority to bully people around and you
just what does the Bible in general say
about quite a bit
now you
won't hear the phrase spiritual abuse
but Jesus talked about wolves in sheep's
clothing Jesus talked about the blind
leading the blind the Bible talks about
priests that are dumb dogs that will not
bark they're supposed to warn the people
about sin and protect the people there's
quite a few passages in the Bible that
talk about people in ministry being
faithful and if they are not they get a
more severe judgment according to James
so boy I I'll tell ya there's I can't
even think of all the different places
where God warns his priests and his
ministers you got the story where the
sons of Eli hophni and Phinehas were
slain by the Lord because of their bad
behavior in the sanctuary as well as
nade a band a by hew the sons of Eli
fire came down from heaven and devoured
them because they went into the temple
drunk and so you God gives you know
Jesus you read was it Matthew 23 where
he talked about the scribes and
Pharisees hypocrites that they would put
burdens on people they would not lift
with one of their fingers and that they
robbed widows houses and then pray long
prayer so they can look spiritual so
yeah Jesus said a lot of strong things
about false ministers yeah that's
Matthew 23 verse 4 that's referring to
so yeah boy I tell you Johnny there's
quite a bit there you just won't find
the phrase spiritual abuse but it's that
principle people use abusing their
spiritual authority thank you again for
answering my question I really
appreciate God bless you guys all right
thanks so much appreciate your call
Aloha well Penn said are we looking at
the clock I don't know if we have time
to take another call just before we have
my breaking you the music route hey
friends don't go anywhere we've got some
of the best Bible questions are still
lined up be right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love and great sacrifice but
behind them is another hero hidden in
plain sight amid the shadows he was
there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767 it is not subject to the
50% deduction limit and your gift helps
amazing facts bring people to Jesus call
amazing facts today to see how we can
help you get the most out of your IRA
the number to dial is eight hundred four
three six two six nine five or visit my
legacy dot amazing facts dot org if
you've missed any of our amazing facts
programs visit our website at amazing
facts org there you'll find an archive
of all our television and radio programs
including amazing facts presents one
location so many possibilities amazing
facts org
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 7 to 97 and
want to welcome our friends who are also
watching on either YouTube or Facebook
at the amazing facts channel at the doug
batchelor channel and i am doug
batchelor my name is john ross I am
pastor degree ready to go to the phone
lines on ex-colleagues Marcos and he's
listening in Huntsville Alabama Marcus
welcome to the program hey how you doing
hi how are you doing well hey I got a
quick question well it may not be as
quick thank you this revelation 11 talks
about the two witnesses and at first I
was believing this would be the only New
Testament but as far as I'm reading it
I'm starting to see something a little
bit different seeing is that it when it
says that is the olive tree and the lamp
stands there it could be the Hebrews and
the Gentiles which would make up the
church who are the witnesses who the
beast rises up out of the abyss and
kills them you know you're you're on the
right track about it being the Word of
God and Word of God believed by both
Jews and Gentiles
sometimes it's referred to as the law
and the prophets or the new and the Old
Testament if you look when he talks
about an olive tree and a lampstand that
comes from the book of Zechariah correct
and the you know the Bible tells us thy
word is a lamp unto my feet and the the
Holy Spirit is like the oil that came
from the olive trees and so and that's
Zechariah 4 2 3 verse 11 and 14 so all
of the symbols about the two witnesses
are characteristics of the Word of God
it says that they can shut up the
heavens they can bring plagues you find
plagues in the old and the New Testament
you find famine in the old and the New
Testament and it just it's a symbol for
the law and the prophets Moses and
Elijah you know the last prophecy in the
Old Testament said remember the law of
Moses behold I send you Elijah that
represents the law and the prophets the
Word of God you know I have a book I've
written on this I'll be happy to send
your free copy Marcus and it's called
the two witnesses all you left to do to
receive the book is just call us on our
resource line that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and
after the book called the two witnesses
it's just a great study dealing with
Revelation chapter 11 I'm happy to send
that to anyone who calls and asks we've
got Rajjo is listening from Colorado
Raja welcome to the program thank you
for accepting my child yeah
I have an interesting question I've been
studying revelation with a couple other
people now they're coming up with a
different word for world or earth and it
says the meaning of it is region is
there a Greek word for won't well that
depends on what verse let me see here
there is a Greek word for world you get
you know is it
Teairra and matter of fact when it talks
about the earth there's also a Greek
word for the word earth and that can
mean the ground
NASA Ross might be looking them up right
now from the look on his face yes I'm
just looking at a few fret there's quite
a few actually
revelation they've talked about the
world and the one that I'm looking at is
Revelation chapter 13 talks about all
the world worshipping the beast power
and you also have the word earth used in
Scripture as well so what it talks about
the world it's just talking about the
inhabitants of the world and it talks
about them worshiping the Beast and when
it talks about the earth it's referring
more to the land so to speak which in
symbol represents a sparsely populated
area you'll notice the second beast of
Revelation 13 comes up from the earth
and that's revelation 13:11 so yeah I
think one of them where it talks about
the whole world to test in a revelation
3:10 it's all kinda - I might be
pronouncing that wrong and it means the
inhabited world a populated a populated
place so that word I think appears a
number of times in Greek and it could
mean inhabited regions so that that's on
the line with what you were saying so I
hope that helps a little bit yes because
I've got somebody telling me that when
it talks about the world it's talking
mainly about the region like the world
will see when he returns and he says no
it's only going to be that region that
pierced him I said no my Bible says the
world will see him well you know another
reason you're correct is when it says in
Revelation he comes in the clouds and
every eye will see him well that's
pretty comprehensive every eye is gonna
see him and that's talking about the
matter of fact I think it says all the
tribes of the earth will mourn its
revelations so it's not just one country
or one region that's going to see it
that's gonna affect everybody good
question Roger thank you next color that
we have is Roberta listening from South
Carolina
Roberta welcome to the program Roberta
hi get real close to your phone here me
that's better okay
my question is on X and we find it x-23
8 it says for the sadducees say that
there is no resurrection neither Angels
nor spirit but the Pharisees confessed
yes what is the spirit that is being
referred to in this text well the fair
I'm sorry the Sadducees were a very
liberal sect of the Jews and they didn't
believe an angel is a spirit and so they
said well we don't believe in angels or
other spirits meaning cherubim Seraphim
these other creatures of God that are
invisible to us the Bible calls them
ministering spirits and they're living
intelligent creatures Paul says you know
we don't wrestle against flesh and blood
but against you know principalities and
powers these are the ministering spirits
are the evil spirits in high places
right and I think that's also part of
the references that you gotta angels on
the good side and then sometimes the
fallen angels are referenced as spirits
or evil spirits and I think it's
addressing both that's right
fallen angels as well as good angels the
Sadducees didn't believe in any of that
they didn't even believe in the
resurrection yeah they just thought this
was it for the Greek there refers to the
same as angels well it's two different
words but the angel is described as a
spirit in the Bible and then evil
spirits or fallen angels also reference
the spirits the word spirit there is
from the Greek word pneuma and it's it's
used interchangeably with breath they
used it for spirit for it could be a
presence or a supernatural being so
that's the same word that's used many
times in the New Testament in the Greek
so that it means they didn't believe in
the angel or the spiritual world it mean
good or bad angels don't agree just me
man yeah the word is numa I'm looking at
it right now
hey well we appreciate that I'm trying
to think what we have that would give
you more information online called
angels it talks about angels but we do
have a lesson that's called messages
from outer space talks about three angel
messages yes and if you'd like to
receive that study guide it's called
angel messages from space the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can ask to the
study guide called angel messages from
space
next quarter that we have is Andy
listening in Fort Worth Texas Andy
welcome to the program hi how are y'all
this evening do it good thank you for
calling Eddie it's definitely not
pleasure I just want to tell you how
much I've enjoyed your shows and how
much it's challenged me to learn more
and just thank you for being on the
radio this evening I was really shocked
I was driving home and I heard you know
I thought oh my gosh I've wanted to
speak to you so many times watching your
show and I have about ten questions but
I'm going to ask you probably what I
think is the most difficult one that I'm
struggling with and I would just really
appreciate your opinion I originally
called said I wanted to speak to you
about God's will which I do but it's the
third part of my question and I also
want to tell you how much I enjoyed your
personal testimony which I saw on
television and I just really took me
back I really it's really been
impressive to me I I grew up not really
believing in the Bible I've got a
master's degree in biology and I just
couldn't see how evolution in the Bible
or two that could combine and then one
day some gentleman pointed out to me the
errors in evolution and then I began to
see the the truth in Genesis and then
the Bible just broke wide open to me hmm
and now I see all scripture I mean I see
it as black and white you know it's
either All or Nothing and I see all the
scriptures as having to be true and
because of that this is my question to
you in Philippians 2 verses 10 and 11 it
talks about the name of Jesus it says
every knee shall bow those on heaven and
earth and it says and under the earth
and it says that every tongue should
confess that Christ that Jesus Christ
and His Lord and to the glory of God and
then one day in a Bible study I was
sitting there and they put John 6:40 up
and it says for this is the will of my
father that everyone who believes and
behold the son
and may have eternal life and that I
myself will raise him up on the last day
and then I know from Romans 10:9 that if
you're willing to confess Jesus as Lord
that you would be saved and I just sit
there and I looked at that and I said
well if all three of these scriptures
are true which I know they are then I
think that the people that are under the
earth have an opportunity to be saved
and I said that I was just ostracized
you know people just immediately just
slammed and said oh no no no well you
know that hurt me and he was probably
got to dive in here and start
formulating and an answer for you go
ahead but you're probably the the whole
premise is going to be what does it mean
when it says under the earth yeah now
you're you're assuming I think that it
means those under the earth mean people
who are dead and buried yeah you know I
think Paul is referring back to a
statement about God when he when Moses
said the truth is not up in heaven that
you've got to go get it it's it's not
down in in the ocean it's very near to
you
there's several references about God and
heaven above and earth beneath it's not
talking about dead spirits when he says
every creature they haven't above or the
earth beneath you know the Bible even
talks about every creature is gonna
praise the Lord there are some creatures
that live in the ocean is I don't think
he's talking about in the graves there
because they had another word for that
just to add a little thing there Andy
there will be a confession of even even
the wicked they will finally acknowledge
that God is true that Jesus is Lord but
it's not going to be an acknowledgment
or a repented sort of acknowledgment
you'll remember the story when Judas
betrayed Jesus and then suddenly he
realized fully what he had done and he
took the money back and he threw it on
the floor the temple and he said I've
betrayed innocent blood and went out and
he hung himself that that was not
repenting
of what he had done he just realized the
truth came to him that you know here
betrayed Jesus so I think at the end of
time Pharaoh did yeah
at the end of time even the wicked will
recognize that they've been warring
against God and it's true Jesus is the
Lord so they will acknowledge that but
it's not a repentant type of confession
that the Bible speaks of is necessary
for salvation
do you believe and preach that Jesus
went to hell
that he died and went to hell and took
the keys and I mean is that is that
scripturally accurate no people read a
verse in first Peter they say that you
know it talks about through which Spirit
Christ preached to those spirits in
prison when the long-suffering of God
waited in the days of Noah and everyone
thinks well the spirits in prison what
does that mean it's just saying it's the
same spirit and what you've got that
verse here I do 1st Peter chapter 3
verse 19
yeah it's saying the same spirit that
preached in the days of Noah remember
when God said my spirit will not strive
with man for he is also flesh that same
spirit as a spirit that rose Jesus it's
not saying Jesus when he died on the
cross he went to give a second chance to
people who had died from the days of
Noah
that's totally contrary to everything
the Bible says where it says it's
appointed unto man once to die and after
that the judgment after person dies
their destiny is sealed they don't get a
second chance to hear the gospel again
so yeah I think that's a frequently
misunderstood verse and you don't want
to build a doctrine on just one verse
you know we do have a study guide that I
think Amy you'll find very interesting
it's it's simply called
all the dead really dead and it gets
into this whole subject and I think even
addresses those verses we're talking
about him for his Peter we'll be happy
to send that to you for free all you're
left to do is just give us a call the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and just asked for the study guide
called are the dead really dead and
thank you for your call Andy good glad
we got a chance to talk god bless all
right next caller the behalf is Jes
listening from Bakersfield California
oh yeah yes welcome to the program Jason
Bakersfield
yes yes yeah you might turn your radio
down just so you could get confused will
get confused too oh yeah
question on the Book of Leviticus
chapter 11 okay
we're talked about we talked about the
unclean animals yeah
and it says you'll be unclean until the
evening what exactly does that mean
well there's two different things you
weren't just unclean until the evening
if you ate an unclean animal they
weren't supposed to eat the unclean
animals if you touch the carcass of an
unclean animal you know you know might
have a donkey that died and you had to
move the donors dead body or something
you know just it's basic laws of
Sanitation and contamination that you
weren't supposed to we're putting you on
mute because we're getting a lot of
background noise you you weren't
supposed to be touching something and
matter of fact they had laws that if you
had a a steel pot and you found a dead
rat in it you could wash that and it
would be clean but if it was a clay pot
he had to destroy it because it would
sort of permeate the the clay and it was
all sanitation really I think any
parting Levitical law any bodily a
mission you were considered unclean and
no does that help purchase oh thank you
very much I appreciate that god bless
god bless and I think we've got a study
guide that talks about some of the
Levitical laws and well I was thinking
about death in the kitchen good book
that is that is we'll be able to submit
to anyone who calls and ask just simply
called death in the kitchen got an
intriguing title then I'm gonna call his
800 eight three five six seven four
seven you can answer the book called
death in the kitchen next caller that we
have is David David listening I believe
in these that Mississippi David welcome
to the program here in Missouri Missouri
okay yeah and your question
my question is that if I'm paying 10% to
the change and I'm seeing the changes
not doing they're supposed to do
preaching the gospel like the playing
the money or any reason so you sucker
for me give them five percent and a
purpose and use it like fine any
organization seeing doing word of God
because it's my children member and God
require me to pay 10% my income but I
can see that the job have been done so I
looked look like my money being used
something else so he's looking for me to
use to give them five percent and I take
five percent see whatever those any
organization seen you doing will of God
so he said that I think I understand
your question so if if you know the
Bible tells us to bring all of the
tithes into the storehouse and if every
member says well you know I don't know
that I have confidence in the way that
the work is being done with church
leadership I'm gonna pick a different
way or I'm gonna divide the percentage
differently you know the work of God
could break down pretty quickly on an
international basis if we do that I
think in the Bible about the story where
Hannah even though the Bible says elion
has not alized so much but the sons of
Eli were mismanaging what was happening
in the temple god still blessed hannah
when she brought her son and made an
offering of her son when the widow came
to the temple in the days of Jesus and
Jesus saw her about to put in her last
two mites Jesus could have said don't do
that the priests here corrupt most of
them anyway and are just put in one
might and give the other to me you know
Jesus said God was gonna bless her for
putting in her two mites God blesses
when we give to him if people if there
are men or women that mismanage the use
of the money they'll have to answer to
God for that but if you're going to a
church you want to be faithful in
supporting the church you attend
otherwise it's kind of like you know
you've got a wife and a girlfriend in
another city that you're supporting you
you want to be supporting the church
where you're attending and you're
getting all the benefits
a thank you and we do have a study guide
that talks about that subject David yes
to receive that study guide just call
NASA it's called in god we trust' and it
deals with finance and what the Bible
says about that and how our offering
some type is to be used the number to
call is eight hundred eight thirty five
six seven four seven and just ask to the
study guide called in god we trust' we
have faith who's listening from texas
faith welcome to the program faith in
lubbock faith are you on mute we can't
hear you
faith going once we've got john in
washington john welcome to the program
john you there yes i am hi thank you
yeah thanks for taking my call
I have a question I believe it's a Bible
verse or part of one that says if God be
for us who can be against us and is that
in the Bible and we're I think it's in
Romans chapter eight I'm looking it up
right now let me see here yeah it's in
Romans chapter eight 31 what shall we
say then to these things if God be for
us who can be against this I think Paul
is talking here in Romans about if if
the Lord is forgiving us and he's
justifying us if you look at the
previous verses he says moreover he whom
was predestined these also he called who
he called he justified who he justified
these he clarified what shall we say to
these things if God is for us who can be
against us and he that did not spare
here's the next verse he that did not
spare his own son but delivered him up
for us all how shall he not with him
also freely give us all things in other
words Jesus God has given his son to
redeem us he's made a heavy investment
to make it possible for us to be saved
how can man keep us from being saved if
God has done so much to save us yes
well thank you very much absolutely and
so it is there it's in as I said Romans
8:31 appreciate your call okay thank you
bye bye-bye
next holder that we have is Ramona
listening from South Carolina
Ramona welcome to the program well thank
you thank you I'm glad I got you well we
got a couple minutes so how can we help
you tonight well I am wondering if this
is a Sabbath question what would it be
breaking the Sabbath for me to it oh
don't tell us we got cut off
I think Tim you still there Ramona I'm
here do you hear me yeah so you're
asking would it be breaking the Sabbath
for you to attend a like a Bar Mitzvah
or temple service it's actually a bat
mitzvah for a for my knees girl yeah on
a Saturday morning well in most cases I
would say no it's a spiritual event now
I come from a Jewish background and
you've got different kinds of it's just
like a wedding you can go to a Christian
wedding and it'd be a sacred service and
then you can go to a wedding that is not
so christian or pretty liberal and
there's a lot of drinking dancing people
you know walking around with underwear
on their head you never know what you're
gonna see it a wedding when they start
to celebrate so it depends well this
celebration this the celebration is
actually after sundown so this is a
morning service you know I'd say by all
means the bar mitzvah is a time to about
mitzvahs
time to celebrate a spiritual transition
for a young lady and if you could
support your family by going what do you
think pastor Ross I think it might be a
good spiritual event yeah I think so
yeah nothing wrong with spending time
with family and on the Sabbath you'll be
in a religious house of worship I'm so
happy to hear that because I've been
getting con just different feedback I am
my families have tuition have Christians
so and and the house Christian our you
know Sabbath chambers well through the
original Sabbath keepers were Jewish
that's right now now what's ironic is
most of the people attending this really
don't keep the sabes so it's in a temple
this or sabbath-keeping well you might
be able to be a witness there it's you
know technically there should be a rabbi
there and it would be a sacred occasion
he'll be quoting from the Torah yes and
so you know hopefully you can be a
witness it's not something that you do
you know Paul says I become all things
to all men that I might reach some for
Christ and Paul specifically says to the
Jew I became as a Jew that I might reach
the Jews amen so you know you'll have to
pray I'm not the Holy Spirit but I would
probably not lose any sleep over that
and I have Jewish family I've had the
same kind of conundrum so I understand
that I'm delighted to have gotten
through and and your you know your
wisdom and your opinion they do count
but but yes ultimately it's prayer and
and you know seeking the Holy Spirit to
prompt me amen you know and we we have a
new book that we put out let's talk
about keeping the Sabbath holy how do
you keep the Sabbath holy and it does
deal with some of these kind of moral
crises or dilemmas or quandary as we say
you know well what should we do and we
can send you a free copy of that I would
love it alright hey thank you so much
Ramona the number to call is 800 eight
three five six seven four seven and
pastor you mentioned the book it's
keeping the Sabbath holy keeping the
Sabbath holy all right just it's all
there in the name mazing thing we put it
out about a year ago and we had a lot of
orders but I don't think we ever
promoted it because it just it was so
popular through the catalog okay you
know we ought to let people know number
he's eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven god bless you you too
and you know I'm looking at the clock
it's counting down 1413 see that 12:10
hey listening friends we'd love to hear
from you in another way if you'd like to
just go to the amazing facts website new
website click donate keep us on this
station god bless you
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit a
book store calm
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaimed
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 macing fax 0 RG
[Music]